arasmus plus welcome to arasmus
Village if you're a teacher youth worker
or lecturer searching for exciting new
possibilities there might be some
professional
development maybe some hands-on
experience in your
field perhaps you're Keen to partner
with a different institution or Youth
Organization
huh or even a business or social
Enterprise ah in a relevant sector oh if
so arasmus plus can
help the new EU program for education
training Youth and Sport will link you
to business's social Enterprises NOS
youth groups and all sorts of Education
institutions ah for some amazing
European
activities
woohoo you can work together to share
teaching practices across Europe you can
link up to run learner and staff
exchanges between countries you can
co-design and improve curricula and
since funding and support are provided
through arasmus plus there's really
nothing stopping
you ask your institution or Youth
Organization to help you to participate
in arasmus plus so you too can engage
with others to modernize teaching and
learn learning in Europe Tada arasmus
plus is an opportunity for you and your
organization to reach your full
potential find out more at ec. europa.eu
Erasmus hyphen Plus or join the
conversation on social
media